pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
Monsieur papendaï Merci Merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs le
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Max
Brisson je m'associe bien sûr à
l'hommage que vous venez de rendre à
Agnès LaSalle assassiné dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions elle consacrer sa vie à
ses élèves et mes pensées vont à sa
famille à ses collègues et à ses élèves
tout atteinte contre un professeur porte
atteinte à la République c'est ce que
j'ai dit sur place avec Stanislas
Guérini le ministre de la Fonction
publique avec vous-même avec la
sénatrice espagnole il y avait que le
maire de Saint-Jean-de-Luz Jean-François
Irigoyen
à propos de votre question la carte
scolaire tient compte bien sûr d'une
manière générale de la baisse des
effectifs scolaires qui sera j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire dans cette
hémicycle très importantes l'année
prochaine ce qui nous amène à fermer des
classes ici à en ouvrir là dans votre
département des Pyrénées-Atlantiques
nous comptons environ 450 élèves de
moins l'année prochaine tout en veillant
à ce que le taux d'encadrement
particulièrement dans les régions
rurales continuent de s'améliorer ce qui
sera en effet le cas dans votre
département des ajustements d'ici au
mois de juin vont avoir lieu en
particulier sur quelques points
sensibles
éventuellement ceux que vous connaissez
tout en donnant priorité au RPI les
regroupements pédagogiques
intercommunaux donc aux zones rurales à
propos de pluriannuel nous avons un
regard pluriannuel sur les évolutions
démographiques qui nous est fournie par
les statistiques du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale ainsi que par les
rectorats mais il faut aussi tenir
compte des variations annuelles des
migrations des familles qui s'installent
des déménagements ce qui oblige
effectivement à construire annuellement
une carte scolaire mais nous proclame
encore au stade des ajustements je vous
remercie monsieur Brisson
iques je vous ai parlé de procédures de
la carte scolaire je crois qu'il est
grand temps que l'on travaille avec les
acheteurs d'élus pour entrer dans une
démarche plus réelle les mères n'en
peuvent plus d'avoir un comptable chaque
année dans leurs écoles qui viennent
calculer le nombre d'élèves alors qu'ils
savent comme lotissement est en cours de
préparation et que dans un an dans deux
ans il y aura un nouveau des enfants
c'est cette vision comptable qu'on vous
demande d'abandonner pour une démarche
plus réelle
[Musique]